so stochastic control is a huge subject
and I will sort of build up to it but as
a cartoon this is the picture that I
that I want you to have in mind there's
a complicated system and we have
indications about its state but we can't
observe the state directly and we also
have actions that we can take by turning
knobs and each of these actions jiggles
the state of the system not by very much
and what we're hoping to do is we're
going to try to achieve to bring the
system to an acceptable state and the
general idea is that the set of
acceptable states is an exponentially
small fraction of the entire state space
so it's not an easy thing to do in our
goal is to drive the system in that
direction so a realistic example of
stochastic control would be something
like this this is a theory talk so we'll
simplify simplify things a lot so I will
start from somewhere that seems
relatively far away I will start with
the so-called lavas local Emma and the
probabilistic method so the
probabilistic method what we do is we
want to exhibit that object with certain
good properties exist in this case for
us in the background overhead is the
idea of state that were happy with and
in order to demonstrate that these
objects exist we place a probability
distribution over state space and then
argue that the desirable states have
nonzero probability and desirability is
typically framed by defining a
collection of bad things that can happen
things that can go wrong and the state
is good if in that state none of the bad
things is happening so you have a
probable this is just pure probability
you have Robin airy space you have a
collection of bad events and then
obviously if the events were independent
then the probability that no bad event
occurs is simply the product of the
compliments of the probabilities of the
bad events and this is always strictly
positive as long as no bad event is
deterministic the problem is around the
vast majority of interesting scenarios
the bad events are not independent from
another and in particular you're in a
situation in which avoiding one bad
event increases the probability of some
other bad event it boosts it so let me
give you an example imagine I wanted to
prove to you that this form will I
satisfiable and the way to do it would
be to look at the binary cube there's
three variables so I'll take the uniform
measure on the cube and then I will try
to prove that you know with this is some
truth assignment dissatisfying so has a
satisfying assignment has nonzero
probability so if i define my events to
correspond to the violations of the
clauses then this event over the uniform
measure of violation has probability one
quarter the problem is if I expose to
you that this clause is happy this bias
is variable x2 you know it makes it a
bit more likely that it is one which
suggested that this clause is less
likely to be happy another way to think
about this is if you sort of think
geometrically if you think of the volume
of your probability space you have your
different events if the events are
independent then their intersections
must have size exactly proportional to
the product of the events but if you
vents are dependent then they are
allowed to be repulsive with respect to
one another and therefore in aggregate
occupy even more volume potentially
covering the entire space so you can
interpret the lavas local Emma are
saying that in the presence of limited
amounts of dependence you can still
prove that the union of the bad events
doesn't occupy the entire probability
space and the simplest formulation of
the lemma says the following assume that
everybody event has probability at most
P and moreover it is independent of all
other events except for up to Delta
other bad events then if P times Delta
is less than 1 over Euler's constant
then the probability that nothing bad
happens is strictly positive
yeah so one of the nicest applications
of of the lavas local emma is to show
that every case enf formula in which
each clause shares variables with at
most two to the K over each other
closest is satisfiable and the proof is
very straightforward we just say take
the uniform measure over the probability
space so over the binary tubes over the
two to the N possible assignments and
observe that under the uniform measure
each Clause is violated with probability
2 to the minus K moreover if I tell you
this some clauses satisfied or violated
when this clause doesn't share variables
with some other clothes then obviously
this imposes no information about this
other clothes therefore the local lemma
sense the number of clauses with which
you share variables is an upper bound on
the number of other bad events with
which you may not be independent so what
you need is that P times Delta is less
than 1 over e so P is 2 to the minus K
which applies a delta can be as high as
2 to the K over now in spite of the fact
that this was incredibly effortless it
also turns out to be tight and proving
that statement is far harder okay but it
should give you some idea that the lavas
local emma is not a toy it can actually
get to the edge if the only thing that
you know about your formula structurally
is the number of intersection it
actually takes you to be sort of to the
edge of to the edge of reality so
now after you know that satisfying
assignments exist or more generally
after you have demonstrated that the
object that you want exists the next
question is how to find them and there
was a after the lavas local Emma started
you know dominating probabilistically
networks there was a lot of effort to
make it constructive meaning to come up
with an algorithm which will import
nominal time actually find an object
find an element of the probability space
that simultaneously avoids all that
event it was a sequence of papers the
conditions though required were
significantly more stringent than what
the existential dilemma requires and
then in 2009 Robin Moser had a
breakthrough in which he showed that
least for the problem of satisfiability
you could get Delta to be pretty much
right except up to you know to a
polynomial factor and moreover it turns
out that Moses ideas if you're a little
bit more careful get you exactly what is
what is it have it so in polynomial time
you can find a satisfying assignment
under under this condition and what is
perhaps even more remarkable is the
simplicity of of Moses algorithm so this
is a three CNF except that when a light
bulb is lit it means that the clause is
unhappy okay that's why it's red so if
it is silent it means that the closest
happy and blue versus that color is
whether the light bulb wants the switch
to be 0 or 1 so losers algorithm sets
start at an arbitrary configuration of
the switches and then in every round
just pick uniformly at random and
unhappy close a little light bulb and
then without looking at the current
state just read jiggle the switches that
correspond to the unhappy light bulb so
in this particular example you know
let's say I would pick this one and then
I won't even look at what this are set
at I'll just rest and she ate the three
variables corresponding to this clause
with equal room will it be 5050 and then
the theorem is that in fact in linear
time linear in the number of variables
on the number of clauses this will find
this
I assignment under the condition of the
of the novice LOL oh so it enjoyed work
with 40 syllables we sort of tried to
introduce a generalization that would
allow you to apply similar ideas in a
broader concept and we we developed what
we call the flaws action framework so we
take omega is a big arbitrary set so
this is our state space so this is the
equivalent of a probability space except
I haven't talked about probabilities yet
and then we have subsets that we call
flaws so when a state is in here it
means it sort of suffers from this love
we group together states according to
some particular deficit that they have
and our question of interest is whether
there exists states that escape the
union of the flaws that we call flawless
and the general idea is that if such
states exist we would like to discover
them in time which is significantly
smaller than on the size of Omega and
the plan for doing it is we're going to
implicitly specify a directed graph on
the entire state space such that every
float object has out degree at least one
so if you're in a bad place there's some
work to go on the other hand every
project object is a sink so you're happy
there and we're going to start at an
arbitrary state so it's enough to get
any kind of foothold into the state
space and then from there we will take a
random walk until we reach a flawless
subject until we reach I think that's
the that's the general plan more
concretely as a way that we will
implement the plan is if this is our
current state let's say Sigma we are
going to look at the flaws that are
present in the state so Sigma suffers
flow and flow one and flow three and
we're going to select one of those flows
at random and we will try to jump out
we will try to escape and the way we
will try to escape sort of the obvious
one we're going to have some transitions
hopefully most of them us will take
outside the flow but some of us might
actually keep us inside the flow okay
that's the that's the general idea so
for any flood state for every floor
present in the state you have some
choice of actions that you can take over
probability distribution and the overall
algorithm is whenever you're in a flood
state pick one of the flaws uniformly at
random and just try to fix it okay and
then the question is will this ever
converge because obviously when you try
to fix something you might break you
might break something else these are
there any questions up to here or we
just come from I haven't I haven't said
anything yet yep I just wanted to make
sure that these numbers are up to one
that's that's the only thing is all
right
so just as an example to keep in the
back of your head if we have AK CNF
formula with n variables and M closest
our big space is the binary cube the
flaws corresponds to the closest in the
sense that they are the sub tubes that
violate each of the closest so f1 is all
the states in which close one is
violated and then the arcs or actions
for addressing flow I at a given state
remember that a flow corresponds to a
close are all the possible two to the K
mutations of that particular clause so
when I said you can rejigger the
variables of that closers to decay
possible ways of doing it and then
finally the probabilities to ask motions
case in that particular case they're all
equally probable so this is how Moses
algorithm will fit in the flow section
screamer okay so now in order to get to
get a theorem that says this will finish
at a reasonable amount of time I start
to have getting it I have to become a
little bit quantitative and there is a
few quantities that I but I need to
discuss but not many so let Rho sub I
Sigma Tau denote the probability that i
will go from state Sigma to state towel
when addressing flow I at state Sigma so
I'm at let's say some particular tweet
assignment close I is violated what's
the probability that i will go to state
tell ok so this probability distribution
at a particular state has some entropy
and so this is the entropy of the
probability distribution for addressing
flow I at state Sigma it is just the
entropy of those three arcs that I said
and now I'm going to take the minimum of
this
overall the states in the floor so what
essentially this is saying is when my
state suffers from flow I how much
entropy at least will I inject into the
system in my effort to perform state
space exploration it's a uniform right
all the same no in general this is an
arbitrary probability distribution
example that's right for the previous
example that was the same way that's all
it's a uniform children distribution
folder signal okay okay yes all right it
was even on the same slide so so is it
clear so I want this quantity to be big
right because if this quantity is big it
sort of suggests that my actions tend to
explore the state space because they
have to go to many many different places
there's lots of destinations and I sort
of visit all of them with reasonable
probability so I want the local entropy
of each flow to be a large quantity now
that in and of itself is not enough
because in principle you could imagine
that all the different actions for
getting out of a particular state end up
going to the same place so for example
here this is a state in which I have a
chance of getting to both from here and
from here so if all of the outgoing arcs
in some sense were contained in a tiny
part of the state space this would
create congestion so I want to avoid
congestion so on one hand I want the
image of this transformation to be
uniform over the state space to be large
so that I explore the state space but I
also I don't want there to be
commissioned so that it is genuinely
large and because I want to have a local
characterization of what this means the
way that I'm going to talk about
congestion is sort of rather brute
specifically we're going to define this
quantity we're going to say take an
arbitrary state towel not necessarily in
a specific flow or not and look at the
number of states for which this is a
possibility in flow
I in other words when I'm addressing
flow I from how many different states of
that flow may I end up in town so this
is basically just the indegree so this
has in degree 1 viscous in degree 2 and
because we want to eventually compare
this with an entropy we're just going to
measure this in a logarithmic scale and
then finally because we want the local
characterization we're going to take the
maximum over Omega no no and that's part
of the entropic part in the title of the
talk it's just going to be counting yes
yes yes yes in general this sort of
doesn't typically happen in applications
more or less i will say but let me do
question is well posed right is a
meaningful question but i won't deal
with this I just deal with this in this
sense and in particular I claim that the
congestion of every flaw in Moses
algorithm is zero and the reason this is
0 not one is remember we're taking a
logarithm so essentially what i'm saying
is that if this is evaluated close and i
look at all the outgoing arcs there are
never collisions the reason to see this
is imagine this is a state and i told
you i arrived at that state because I
fixed a specific claw well that claw was
violated in the previous date and
there's only one way for a cloth to be
violated by the nature of such viability
okay in general the congestion is what
it is ok so those two quantities local
entropy on one hand and lack of
congestion on the other I can combine
them to define a quantity that I call
the amenability overflow so the Amin
Amin ability is a positive word you want
this quantity to be big so it's the
local entropy I'd be fine minus the
congestion as defined and this is I'm
just now in this I'm just reiterating
what I had in previous slides
so for any particular flow I look at all
the Ark's leaving the flow along with
the associated probabilities and this
allows me to define what the amenability
of the flow is so I mean ability is good
because it suggests search space
exploration at a rapid pace big
amenability now of course achieving big
amenability on its own it's kind of
trivial because what I could do is I
could just literally reset all the
variables in every step then you know
this would basically just be going
everywhere so in reality I want it to be
the case that on one hand I explore the
state space and I typically get out of
the bad set that I try to address but at
the same time I don't break too many
other things I don't introduce too many
flaws into the system and to measure
that we are going to introduce the other
quantity that we need to measure which
I'll call potential causality so this is
a state sigma this is the same
probability distribution as the
probability in the previous slide so to
talk about pause ality actually we're
not going to look at the numbers we're
just going to look at every art for
which the number is nonzero as long as
it is a positive probability accounts
the same so this is the overall picture
I am in state Sigma these are the
possible actions and i will say that a
particular choice of next state when
addressing flow I at state Sigma
introduces so we put in this set every
flaw that is present in the new state
that was not present in the original
state what makes a lot of sense and we
also put the flow itself if we failed to
escape from the set so gamma sub i sigma
tau is i was at sigma i decided to
address flow I I ended up in stage tau
in state tau what flows are present that
were not present in Sigma a
and B did I manage to escape you know
slow I the original state in which I was
that's my set so for example in this
case this arc takes us to this state and
the only relevant state is here so we
introduce flow for if we do this on the
other hand if we look at this arc this
new state belongs both inflow of 3 and
inflow for but observe that flow of
three was already present in the
existing site so this transition only
introduces floor for it doesn't
introduce both three and four and then
finally this tradition this story
distance they should introduces flow one
in the sense that it reintroduces flow
on so overall this particular state
moving away from it has the potential to
cause plus 4 and flow one okay and then
again because I want to have a local
characterization I'm simply going to
define the neighborhood of a flow to be
the union of everything that can be
broken whenever I decide to address that
flow in a state of the flow so it is the
Union over all states in the flow over
all the actions that can possibly take
on those states of what may possibly be
introduced
ok so in Moses algorithm again sort of
our guiding example observe that each
Clause can potentially cause another
clothes only if they share variable if
they don't share a variable you cannot
cause that other close to happen
moreover you have to disagree on that
variable if you agree on that variable
again you can't cause it to happen if it
was unhappy before it wasn't you to you
it's not going to be due to do it you're
in your new state either you'll be happy
together or you'll both be unhappy and
then finally because I said that each of
the two take a 2 to the K possibilities
has equal probability this also includes
the self loop state so there is a 2 to
the minus K probability that you stay
put there for every clause has the
potential to because itself ok there are
there any questions ok so the general
scheme then is we have such system of
laws and actions we start at an
arbitrary state and then what we keep
doing is we say let F sub I be a random
flow present in the current state ok
among the actions available for
addressing the chosen flow in the
current state take one according to the
prescribed ability distribution I'm just
rewriting this notion of how we work in
the state space and then the theorem is
that in this inequality holds for every
flow then there exists some critical
time such that you will walk for about
that long and after that point you'll
have a cut-off phenomenon the
probability you want reaches sake as
steps after you've walked the cut off
time decays exponentially nice so it's
not just polynomial time convergence but
it's more like you walk for a while and
then boom the probability drops very
very rapidly and then what you what you
sum over here on the left hand side is 2
to the minus amine ability of the flaws
that you may cause
soflo I burdens the system in relation
to the flows that it may cause and in
particular the flow that it may cause
our burdensome by 2 to the minus or
amenability so if I Liam enable flow is
not a big deal doesn't contribute much
to this some the point is this is a
relatively easy quantity to compute
because it's the criterion is local and
if we plug this into our sort of running
example observe that the amenability of
each clause in Moses algorithm is K
because you use K random bits in every
step that's the entropy durability
distribution the congestion is 0 because
we took a logarithm so this is K so this
is this inner term is 2 to the minus K
for every flow so you can afford to have
up to two to the K minus two so that
this is less than a quarter so we match
the result except that instead of having
2 to the K divided by E you get to the K
divided by 4 but the difference is I
don't have variables this can be a very
complicated space there's there's sort
of several several advantages to this
formulation these are any question yes
do you have anything on the other
direction to me with that that sound is
too large argue that it you mean like a
negative result well I don't want to go
into too much but actually in a certain
way we can make this become ovary as
well in which case the same counter
example the one that course want to cns
works for both problems okay so so this
was all actually past work it wasn't the
work that I'm sort of really talking
about this was just to set things up and
the the work that I want to talk about
today extends from this observation so
this is moses algorithm and observe that
it has the following delightful property
you don't have to know the state to run
the algorithm
someone can be hiding behind here they
choose the initial state okay and then
they just do the coin flipping for you
this is clear all that they doing is
they're telling you which light bulbs
are on whether you just read jiggle them
observe that for example from this
picture you know very very little about
the current state maybe you know things
about the variables corresponding to
this light bulb and the things about the
three variables corresponding to that
light bulb and these but there's a ton
of things that you actually don't know
okay so this is an algorithm that
manages to work while it has a very very
gentle relationship with the state the
only thing that it needs to know is this
macroscopic feature of which flows are
present in the statement which flows are
not present in the state and it'll still
work so this raises the question of what
happens if the agent that is actually
sort of acting inside the state on our
behalf is imperfect in the sense that
for example the light bulbs are faulty
meaning sometimes the light bulb that
should be on is not on and the light
bulb is on when it's actually off also
what happens when we flipped a coin and
that coin flip correspondent to actually
switching a variable from 0 to 1 except
our command doesn't it get executed and
finally imagine that this agent running
inside here also has a bit of a mind of
their own so they're injecting noise
into the state okay so that the state
drifts away from our action so not only
do our actions not always happen not
only do our actions suffer from the
possibility of being misguided but in
fact there is also internal drift in the
state so the question is can you still
hope to find a satisfying assignment
under this conditions and the reason of
giving the talk is because the answer is
yes and the sense in which the answer is
yes is if we go back to this inequality
when they see the quality hold it holds
with some slack
okay so the point is I can take this
slack which you can interpret as lack of
internal conflict in the system so when
this quantity is small right my system
moves rapidly to a good state so i can
take this lack of internal conflict and
turn it into into noise resistance so
the more slack you have in your formula
with respect to the original criteria
the more noise I will be able to eject
and the way that I will sort of talk
about noise injection is uh it's very
general so let's look at a specific flow
so this is flow one and these were the
transitions under our good algorithm
this is what we want it to happen and we
had numbers on these okay now imagine
that the adversary comes up and they set
up their own collection of Arc's some of
these arcs are arcs that we used to have
but they can also put in arcs that
didn't exist at all and moreover they
can put their own probability
distribution on these arcs whatever they
want and it takes a little bit of
thinking but it's not hard to see that
if you give the adversary this much
power this is enough to simulate all of
the three different things that can go
wrong that I said in the previous slide
okay
so this is the setting so this is how
we're going to model noise and overall
we're going to say that state of
illusion occurs as follows in every step
with probability 1 minus P the system
act normally and with Rob ability peak
the system act according to the
adversary's wishes that's it that's my
model of noise so in every time I take
an action either the system will behave
as its supposed to if that happens with
probability 1 minus P or the system will
act according to this in some sense anti
algorithm imposed by the adversity that
tries to keep me from reaching a good
state put any probabilities on the arcs
give that this graph is completely
arbitrary of course I will quantify the
nastiness of this graph in the next
slide right that's that's the point and
then of course also the value of P would
be a big deal yes the nice thing I think
is that I can do this in a uniform
manner by which I mean that you can
think of the adversary's chain as an
algorithm exactly like my algorithm and
you can go on and compute the same
quantities like local entropy and
congestion and all that yes so in
particular you can say under the
adversary's actions what flows so this
is star for adverse reaction so what
flows can be introduced when we try to
move away from from state I and moreover
what is the worst-case congestion
overall flaws according to the
adversaries algorithm and now I have
this expression which is a little bit
complicated because I want it to be
sharp but it's easy to see that the
dominant term is the probability that we
move according to adverse reaction the
number of flaws that can be introduced
by the adversary that sort of i wouldn't
have introduced and then finally the
worst-case congestion congestion that
the adversary can induce in their own
chain so this gives you a quantity
and then theorem is that you get this
quantity to show up here so when p 0 in
the noiseless case this quantity is 0 so
I just recover the original result and
the more slack you give me in your
standard algorithm then sometimes the
fastest the system would have converged
unperturbed the more noise it can
tolerate and and still converge little
bit confused about the earlier version
of this result but i think i can i can
ask my question of this life of five
minutes so we'll have plenty of time i'm
done so this is next slide so gamma did
not that's not appear in your original
version of the theorem doesn't I
fossilized when you
okay so I am a flow and I want to make
sure that in some sense I play nice with
respect to the system okay what does it
mean the theorem says if every flow
plays nice now what does it mean for a
flaw to play nice we look at the flaws
that may be introduced into the state in
taking actions to get out or flow I okay
and then we look at each one of those
flaws how amenable is it and the more
amenable it is the less it counts
towards the burden that we impose on the
on the system's oh no the gamma is
themed this would be weighted sum rather
than because of how you know certain
actions are taken with very low
probability you landed something else
life yes so this is a corrected tuition
this is a corrected tuition but it is
hard to get away from this being a hard
notion okay so at least later when we
introduced this this noise aspect
observe that we succeed in making this a
soft notion in that the adversary can
make this very big if P is sufficiently
small in other words the typical sort of
the defining feature of the lavas local
msi said the notion of sparsity of
dependencies yes so for the first result
I spoke you want that sparsity of
dependencies and now i'm just going to
on top of that pile and ugly layer yes
and what's nice is that i don't need the
aggie mayor to be sparse if it doesn't
have very high very high intensity
how difficult is it to discover a
structure like this like the transition
structure that will give me the glute t0
I mean this is just generic I have no
answer this is generic algorithm design
like see if the problem it will depend
on how easy it is to to construct this
thing you know up front I mean one way
to think about all this is what we're
doing here is sort of focused sarcastic
local search right we have a collection
of constraints we need to satisfy all of
them in every step we pick one and we
try to make it happy yes now there is an
entire art about choosing among the
possibilities for making it happy so
like to give you an example if you look
at the again at satisfiability you can
say i'm going to pick it violated
clothes and let's see if it has k
variables I'm going to pick one of the K
variables and flip it okay this will
guarantee that this flow let's sorry
that this particular clause will get
fixed of course it might break other
things how should I pick a variable here
is a reasonable thought you could say
variable one if I flip it it fixes five
things it breaks three things if I flip
variable to I fix two things I brake for
things and so on and forth X so these
two numbers what you fix is typically
called make and what you break is
typically called break okay and then if
you want to think a little bit sort of
like a statistical physicist a very
natural probability distribution to use
for selecting which variable to pick is
e to the minus beta bit as positive
number make- break so you think about
the energy of the system lalalalalala
okay guess what it turns out there is
something much better than this which is
this
this is a highly surprising fact okay on
the other hand it is somewhat parallel
with what I'm saying here because
observe that I never talked about what
you fixed when you moved okay so at best
what I talked about can be thought of as
perhaps giving some guidance that is
quantitative on how to to make to make
local selection rules although to be
completely honest I think I don't know
if it has practical value it is good for
proving theorems in the sense you can
prove things in probabilistic community
oryx okay but my intuition is that in
real life instances you can you can make
better choices than the choices that
optimize the criteria that I said
nevertheless I find it somewhat
satisfying that the theoretical criteria
are sort of consistent the removal of
this of this time so I have another
question like that towards that I one
standing the typhoon control and
compression okay yeah so the truth is
this was the first half of the talk okay
so i just talked about sarcastically I
didn't talk at all about entropy
compression I can take one minute
perhaps to talk about that it's still I
think I have 40 minutes on you have one
minute left and I've been answering
questions yes all right so
imagine that you give me a formula and
I'm supposed to execute motors algorithm
okay and we're going to have a deal i'm
going to try a thousand steps if i don't
find a satisfying assignment after those
thousand steps i stop okay we both know
the formula but now i'm going to execute
the algorithm inside this room and
you're going to be sitting outside and
you don't see my random bits all you do
is you hear me sing which clothes i am
actually dealing with in each step okay
clear alright so now fix some particular
sequence of closes clothes 25 followed
by clothes 42 followed by claw 17 and so
on the fourth a thousand you taught them
yes what is the probability this is the
song duo here I claim this probability
is at most 2 to the minus T so to the
de- sorry okay if it's a case EMF to the
1000 and the reason is if we fix this a
priori and let's say i pick my initial
state uniformly at random the
probability that this is violated is 2
to the minus k but then i refresh all
the bits yes so the probability that
this will be violated in the new state
is also at most to the minus K and this
gives me this therefore what I have to
do to prove that I win is to show that
the rate of growth of the set of
possible songs of length T is gamma to
the T for some gamma strictly less than
2 to the K if I can show that there are
fewer than that many songs that I just
take the Union bound and I win ok and
here is the part that is sort of
technically involved here is the
interesting part in principle you could
say hold on a second in any particular
step you could be saying any one of the
many many many many closers in the
system how are you going to get this
base to
small as 2 to the K and the answer to
this is that these songs are sort of not
arbitrary they're highly compressible
and the reason they are compressible is
the following and with this I finish
look at a particular instance of a
clause inside the zone yes except for
the very first one the very first one we
can attribute to initials into the
original state yes but every subsequent
occurrence of that clause in the
sequence is the result of some
transition in which this clause was
happy in someone broke it yes so there
is a causal relationship going backwards
and now the sparsity of my formula is
reflected in the sparsity of the causal
relationship this compresses the sound
this gives me a growth rate less than
something and then by this argument I uh
I get to prove that eventually things
converge
let's pack a speaker oh it's a busy back